I have one of those stranger than fiction
moments for you.
That sounds like it would be a good Monte
Python skit or something.
Donald Trump suggested yesterday that the
Centennial of women's right to vote in the
United States should have been celebrated
sooner, but finally because Donald Trump gets
things done, we're celebrating it and commemorating
it now Trump apparently not realizing that
a Centennial means a hundred years after the
thing, so you do it when a hundred years have
passed, not earlier.
That wouldn't really make sense.
Check this out from an oval office ceremony
yesterday with Trump signing the women's suffrage
Centennial coin act
and have, they've been working on this for
years and years and I'm curious why wasn't
it done a long time ago and also I guess the
answer to that is because now on precedent
we get these, we get a lot of things done
that nobody else got done, but maybe you could
say a few words, you'll start over.
Well, no, it doesn't have to do with you being
president Donald.
It's that it makes sense because it's been
a hundred years.
Of course, the 19th amendment was ratified
in 1920 2020 next year.
The year that's about to start will be 100
years of women's right to vote in the United
States.
It makes a lot of sense when you understand
what a Centennial is.
Evidence of a totally stable genius for sure.
And remember Sarah Huckabee Sanders told us
yesterday, as I told you about, that Donald
Trump reads more than anyone she knows, hard
to believe, hard to believe.
Trump also apparently set to sign into law
that in 2020 everyone is going to get a birthday.
No president before has thought to do this,
but Trump is going to decree that in 2020
everybody who's alive gets a birthday.
Seriously, though, we're having a good time
here watching stuff like this, but it is extra
painful when you realize the amount of power
that this man currently holds and right-wingers
are of course already saying, look, Trump
was making a very subtle joke.
Trump barely understands humor and the only
jokes he's ever made are ones where he makes
fun of people or gives them some kind of a
nickname.
This was not a joke.
This was ignorance and that's it.
The last opportunity to get in on the black
Friday membership special, get on our mailing
list@davidpakman.com midday Friday.
If you're on that mailing list, you will get
an email with a one day only one time.
Use coupon code for a massive membership discount.
Get on that newsletter.
Let me know what you think about Trump's quote.
Joke by sending me a message on Twitter at
the Pacman.
We will take a break and then the last show
before
for the Thanksgiving holiday